hi happy birthday
chicago west and stormy webster
celebrate their fourth birthdays with an
over-the-top bash the theme barbie and
lol surprise dolls the backyard
celebration was a joint party for kim
kardashian and kylie jenner's little
girls i mean it's so exciting the lavish
party featured a giant pink balloon wall
with their names on it shi's in barbie
font and stormies in lol surprise font
so cute shy and stormy also had similar
custom cookies on their epic dessert
table which displayed their perfectly
themed birthday cakes and that table
caught the eye of auntie kourtney
kardashian that's the pooch founder
smelling her way through all the sweets
let's watch that one more time
but it doesn't end there check out this
ice cream truck and huge ball pit filled
with what else lol surprise dolls which
true took full advantage of
the whole day was a family affair the
birthday girl's cousin dream kardashian
rob kardashian's daughter was also there
getting her face painted
of course stormy's dad travis scott was
there that's the goosebumps rapper
holding his little girl and yes the
giant stormy world head made an
appearance as well pass this to my
daughter
who's expecting her second child with
the musician took a moment to show off
her growing baby bump in her chic pink
ensemble i love it
another dad at the party kanye west
although the day originally got off to a
rocky start when yay claimed in a video
shared on instagram that his estranged
wife kim wouldn't tell him the location
of the party he eventually made it
atiana de la hoya travis barker's
stepdaughter shared this video yep
that's yay chatting with kris jenner at
the event you just gotta roll with it
now the grammy winner is currently
co-parenting shai and his three other
kids with kim north saint and salm but
the proud parents are moving on with
their love lives the beauty mogul is
currently dating snl star pete davidson
i like you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
as for kanye he's spending time with
actress julia fox the two have been very
open with their relationship so far just
check out their steamy photo shoot
shared by interview magazine but last
week a source told et kanye is quote
trying to make kim jealous by being very
public with julia turns out kim isn't
phased by it another source tells e.t
quote kim wants to move on from kanye so
she isn't bothered that julia and kanye
are seeing each other kim is happy if
kanye is happy and she is glad that he's
putting his energy into someone else
romantically
[Music]